It’s very important that we have this department
now, at this current time
[Crowds chant, "I  Can't Breathe"]
because our nation needs the kinds of knowledge
that this department produces and will continue
to produce.
Columbia has a longstanding tradition in
what we would call now African-American Studies
or Black Studies, you know, going back to
the days of Franz Boas but even in particular
after 1968
We see ourselves as a Harlem institution.
I mean African-American studies at Columbia
joins the Schomburg and Harlem Stage and the
Studio Museum and all of those like august
Harlem institutions of intellectuals from
the United States, the Caribbean, and Africa,
all of whom are committed to the very best
scholarly work.
We now join them as a full-fledged department
at the University.
I think it will be a hub for faculty, who
are working on a range of  topics and
disciplines, but I think it will also give
undergraduate students, Master’s level students,
and hopefully doctoral students also a hub
and a home for future studies.
What attracted me to come here to Columbia
University was the robust programming that
was already in place. I was part of Manning
Marable’s class that interrogated Malcolm X's life
and his legacy, and I had the most
significant experience that has put me on
the pathway where I am now as a professor
in Africana Studies
One of the great things about, uh, being here
at Columbia
is it’s really easy to get your students engaged in research.
I think the prominence of the new department,
uh, and what makes maybe Columbia unique is
the fact that someone like me who’s an architect
is actually part of that department.
Or you have someone from Journalism like Jelani
Cobb and June Cross who’ve been research
fellows but who can also be engaged in the
department. Or you have Kellie Jones who’s
an art historian involved And I – I think
that will make, uh, the new department actually
quite unique. For example, many of us are
interested in Black feminist perspectives,
like how do you make that a forefront in,
um, a mission statement and how you start
to craft curriculum.
Columbia is coming to this moment a bit later
than other even peer institutions,
but I think that’s a good thing because it’s going
to allow us to kind of do things differently,
from a curricular standpoint, from an institutional
standpoint, than perhaps had been done before
at other Ivy institutions or at public institutions.
So we’ve got a deep and extraordinary bench
of scholars, potential leaders of the department,
but you know, people who are very committed
to teaching and to producing very exciting,
um, innovative scholarship. It’s a wonderful
time to be at Columbia.